you could imagine
that the oceans are actually the largest
battery
we're storing huge amounts of energy in
the oceans
the wave motion can be very deep it can
extend down
several hundred meters and once it gets
to the near shore
from about 50 meters the whole water
column is moving backwards and forwards
as we search for ways to reduce our
reliance on fossil fuels
some are looking to a largely untapped
potential source of renewable energy
in theory waves off the coast of the
united states alone
could generate over 2 trillion kilowatt
hours of electricity a year
enough to power more than half of the
country waves intensify
and subside not as quickly as the wind
and that means that it can produce a
smoother power generation curve
one of the potential advantages of wave
energy
is that it could act as a complementary
source of power
compared to other renewables on the grid
if it were to be scaled up to commercial
scale
for decades engineers have been trying
to convert wave energy
into electricity but a host of
technological
and financial challenges have
complicated their efforts
in the years from around 2006 to 2015
there were a spate of bankruptcies in
the sector and this was largely because
of a lack of kind of continuous
proven projects out at sea with reliable
electricity generation
since then companies have been trying to
develop the technologies at a steadier
pace
and with a smaller cash burn
but the same questions remain can
companies develop devices and
technologies that actually work
is wave energy just a novelty or
something that can become a major
renewable energy source
the sea is a very challenging
environment within which to operate a
power project
so seawater is corrosive and conditions
are very rough
so this means that power projects don't
have a very long lifetime and it
increases operating and maintenance
costs partly because of that
many early wave energy projects hit
rough waters such as the palamus wave
energy converter in portugal
and the isla limpet project in scotland
but that hasn't stopped others from
trying
companies are focused on testing
projects out at sea
proving their durability trying to raise
capital and bring down cost the sector
hasn't really
converged around one single technology
design
and companies are kind of undecided
about which design works best
finland-based aw energy is a veteran in
the sector
the first proof-of-concept of the
company's device was made in the 90s
after diver rauno koivusari observed the
strong back and forth movement of a
hatch cover
in a shipwreck in the baltic sea the
waves are generated
far from the coastline so the wind blows
on the
on the surface of the water causing the
water particles to rotate
and that rotation extends deep down
below the surface and
the waves can be very long they can be
several hundred meters long
and as they come into the near shore
this rotational
energy turns into an elliptical energy
and eventually backwards and forwards as
you probably
noticed if you've been swimming on the
seashore in large waves
you're pulled in and out that's the
energy that we're extracting
there's a sweet spot where we deploy so
around
10 to 15 meters of water depth that's
where there's still
strong wave energy coming in after years
of research
prototyping and testing the company has
deployed wave roller
a 350 kilowatt device in the waters of
portugal
wave roller has an 18 meter wide and 10
meter high steel panel
fixed to the seabed via a floatable
foundation the panel moves back and
forth with the waves
capturing the energy it's submerged in
the
depth of 15 meters so it's it's
protected from the extreme waves
we generate electricity by capturing the
movement with hydraulic circuitry
in a machine room underneath the surface
that hydraulic energy we turn to
electricity with hydraulic accumulators
and
hydraulic motors and also a generator
the wave roller has survived large waves
at sea for over a year
and delivered electricity via an
underwater cable to the grid in portugal
meanwhile the company has won a 2.5
million euro grant
to work on an upgraded version of the
wave roller
aiming to increase the electricity
generation capacity to one megawatt
the upscale device would have a bigger
panel two power takeoff units
and improved software to control the
energy production
we have taken into use a
wave prediction algorithm that kind of
tells us
what kind of waves are coming in to our
device
that gives us few seconds to prepare
for capturing more energy and the
difference in that is significant our
future plans
are to deliver technology around the
world
so i'm hoping we can be
working on on delivering technology to
projects in asia
and and also in the american continent
as well
meanwhile israeli company eco wave power
is taking a different approach to
capturing the power of the ocean
for the company's founder inner bravaman
developing new sources of renewable
energy is a personal mission
i was born in ukraine in 1986 and two
weeks after i was born the chernobyl
nuclear reactor exploded
causing the largest in history nuclear
disaster
i was one of the babies that got hurt
from the negative effects of such
explosion
i had a respiratory arrest and a
clinical death
luckily my mother a nurse approached my
crib on time
and gave me a mouth to mouth
resuscitation which saved my life
i got a second chance in life and
decided to do something good with it
growing up inner wanted to be a
politician to positively change the
world
after working as a translator at a
renewable energy company
she decided to change paths
solar and wind energy were fully
commercialized there were a lot of
amazing technologies implemented
everywhere
i saw that wave energy although it's an
immense source of electricity
the biggest companies in the world are
trying to develop wave energy
with no success and there was kind of a
race going on in the world
of who is the company that is going to
develop a viable wave energy solution
first
in 2011 the then 24 year old inner
co-founded eco-wave power
instead of installing devices offshore
the company's devices are attached to
existing breakwaters
jetties and peers our technology is very
cost efficient
especially in comparison to the offshore
technologies
because we don't need any ships divers
underwater moorings or cables
we install on existing man-made
structures and all our expensive
equipment the generator the hydraulic
conversion unit the automation
is located on land just like a regular
power station
this is the echo wave power conversion
unit
that has been operating in jaffa port
since 2014
until 2020 here you can see how the
technology works
basically the floaters are going up and
down
and pushing the hydro cylinders which
transmit
biodegradable fluid into land located
accumulators
a pressure is being built the higher the
waves the higher the pressure
which is used to turn the hydromotor
which is turning the generators
the whole system is controlled by a
smart automation system
which you can see right here and in case
of upcoming storms
the system automatically raises the
floor above the water level
and keeps them in the upwards position
until the storm passes
the company has been operating a 100
kilowatt grid connected device in
gibraltar since
2016 which is enough to power 100
households
currently inner and her team are working
on another 100 kilowatt project
at the ported jaffa in tel aviv the
project will be also the first time in
the history of
israel that wave energy will officially
connect to the electrical grid
and our goal going forward is to expand
it to all suitable breakwaters in the
city of tel aviv
and to supply significant part of the
city's electricity needs
[Music]
today engineers and entrepreneurs are
still trying to crack wave energy
globally only a few hundred kilowatts of
wave energy are deployed
compared with gigawatts of offshore wind
[Music]
but the field has come a long way in
recent years and with the right
engineering solutions
this new power source could eventually
become competitive
with more mature renewables like solar
and wind
i would have a lot more confidence in
the success of wave energy companies
today as opposed to like 20 years ago
but in the next um few years or
maybe the next couple of decades it will
be more likely to be used in remote
locations
like islands that are otherwise
dependent on expensive diesel power
or out at sea on gas decommissioning
rigs or for powering
underwater autonomous vehicles
so definitely wave energy can compete
with other renewable energy sources
but i personally believe that this is
not a competition
in order to have a 100 renewable energy
friendly world
we need all renewable energy sources to
work together
you